you said this is not predictable this is
totally predictable when you church
you're on time
this is not the place to do that
this is on you until you choose to do
something different this will continue
to happen somebody needs to stand up for
the children of this state or they will
continue to be killed just like they
were killed in ubaldi yesterday
[Music]
this person did abc i guarantee their
legal team has gone through a thought
exercise
drag him out in handcuffs drag him out
in cuffs he believe you're a sick son of
a [ __ ] that would come to a deal like
this to make a political issue here it's
it is a [ __ ] political issue it is a
political issue it's time for the
politics it's time for it folks
clap for beto aurora to stand up for
these six sons of [ __ ] get them
better get them
i hope there's better footage than what
we got here
of this event
uh folks if you're just watching the the
news is uh greg greg abbott the the
governor the murderer
of accomplice murderer greg abbott and
the lieutenant governor right before the
lieutenant governor speak better roar
came into the press conference and
started confronting the governor and the
lieutenant governor good for beto it's
time he came in
and said
look at my [ __ ] face that's right
you're gonna remember this when i come
for your [ __ ] job that's right
look at ted cruz he thinks he's all
tough now
ted cruz standing behind uh governor
greg abbott
there are
there are family members
shut down yeah there are family members
that are pissed off at you i speak
their family members
whose hearts are broken
there's no words that anybody shouting
can come up here and yeah there are you
goddamn right there are you're fired
[ __ ] you're fired that's the word mark
the battery texan
every american
has a responsibility
where we need to focus not on ourselves
and our agendas
we need to focus on the healing and hope
now now now that we can provide to those
who have suffered unconscionable nope
that's not damaged to their lives and
loss of life we need to stop people from
[ __ ] tearing children apart with
semi-automatic rifles one moment in time
innocent people in grocery stores put
aside carrying them apart
ourselves
think about the people who were hurt
shut the
i'm sick of this [ __ ] this time
lieutenant governor will speak
[Music]
you little speech
i'm just about to say
enough time
to discuss and analyze
what happened yesterday and figure out
how to pass over and let people have
even more guns
to hopefully
prevent it from happening
i i really think they're losing the
narrative here and i think better showed
it uh right out in the open
um and he really put him in their place
i hope there's a better footage of that
uh hopefully if you can if you are you
searching for footage of beto i'm
looking on twitter right now um
hopefully there's some better footage
that we can show uh we are we are um 48
minutes past the second hour here on the
tony michaels podcast but if we can find
some of this better
video where we can watch bet o'roark
absolutely [ __ ] destroy
um
here is scott mcfarland let me see if i
can um change the uh
because we were i was gonna stay on for
ted cruz but i don't give a [ __ ] about
him [ __ ] you no i don't care at this
point [ __ ] that guy um
i want to see what beto said about on
this situation
here is uh
looks the better thread it looks like um
did he tweet he's tweeted something in
the last two hours and 14 hours here is
um
scott mcfarlane um
uh it seems to be a screenshot where
beto is being removed and i think this
is him right down here in the bottom
left-hand corner of this screen
um
where beto has come and uh scott says
pedora confronted
governor greg abbott in the middle of a
press conference and the uvalde shooting
again we brought it to you here
um i'm glad i went to that breaking news
for um
to watch beto absolutely eat his lunch
and that's what we need more of folks if
you don't if you don't think that we
need more more of democrats out there
and people who are who are on the side
of pro-democracy to stand up and yell
and scream and to shout and to fight for
the people who who lives they're gonna
save you are outside your [ __ ] mind
we have to have people who are gonna do
this [ __ ] who are gonna confront these
fascists we have to have it they're not
they're not just coming for your
children's safety in the schools they're
coming for their math they're coming for
your consent for them they want to marry
them they don't want to give them
[ __ ] baby formula based on the color
of their skin and how much money their
parents have they're coming for you
we have to have someone that will stand
up
uh amy says here it is 17 hours ago but
she says dear texas governor better
o'rourke is the answer sincerely the
rest of the country who's rooting for
you
beto just made a huge splash in politics
just now um it's likely to change some
of the race
oh 100 you even said um earlier beto
o'rourke just interrupted uh greg
abbott's press conference and said
you're doing nothing thank you beto um
here's the thing that type of action is
the [ __ ] that we need to do we can't sit
by and wait and say well i hope these
lawmakers finally pass a bill that's uh
actually going to be good for us and and
be the be the the great thing that we
need
[ __ ] that you need to get angry you need
to go vote you need to make sure that
your voice is heard literally heard
going and speaking out against people
like greg abbott and lieutenant governor
and ted cruz in states like texas and
other [ __ ] ass backwards states where
they're trying to take away laws or let
you marry kids or banned books or
whatever it is
you need to take this as an opportunity
to stand up and speak out whether it's
behind the keyboard whether it's voting
or whether you physically actually show
up and protest
here is a screenshot that um
rachel biddick offers got caught uh from
the msnbc feed here our msnbc excuse me
feed from the press conference where
better heroic approached the stage you
can see the lieutenant governor giving
him the uh
enough of that sir um rachel says thank
you beto let's see if we can find
more footage in this um
i'm not finding any footage yeah i'm not
finding any footage right now i'm sure
something will come out momentarily i'm
sure somebody
yeah
you know screenshot it
hopefully there's someone um up close
here that had
um because there's a lot of cameras up
here up front so hopefully someone
caught this and and post this oh you
know what i got one for you
yeah send me a link there and i'll bring
it up here again we're 52 minutes past
the second hour here on the tony
michaels podcast um stick with us here
we're going to try to get you some
footage
of beto o'rourke up close and personal
we can do something right now but if we
continue to accept this then it is on us
it's not just the governor's fault it is
on us i'm not going to accept it so i'm
here i'm calling attention to this and
i'm asking all texans of good conscience
and i could care less whether you're a
republican a democrat or an independent
to stand up right now for yourself for
your kids for our families and to stop
the next shooting just like this one and
what do you say something sir
[Music]
he should not have been able to buy an
ar-15 right there do you want a solution
stop selling ar-15s in the state of
texas you want a solution
have universal background checks we
don't have them you want a solution red
flag laws or extreme risk protection
orders which stop a shooting before it
happens you want a solution safe storage
laws those are four solutions that have
been brought up by the people of texas
each one of those has broad bipartisan
support right now we could get that done
if we had a governor who cared more
about the people of texas than he does
his own political career or his field to
the nra and if you need any proof of
that check the schedule for the nra's
convention this friday right here in the
state of texas five of the worst mass
shootings in u.s history right in the
state on his watch what does he do about
it he goes to the nra convention to brag
about how easy he has made it to
purchase guns in this state and to carry
them
publicly without a background check
without any training or vetting
whatsoever it is absolutely wrong in
fact it is insane the governor talks
about mental health it is insane that we
allow an 18 year old to go in and buy an
ar-15 what the hell did we think he was
going to do with that
this one is on us and what do you say to
texas governor greg abbott who says now
is not the time to make this political
now is the time to stop the next
shooting
right after santa fe high school was the
time to stop the next shooting right
after el paso was the time to stop the
next shooting right after midland odessa
was a time to stop the next shooting and
in each case we say this isn't the time
now is the time like literally right now
that's why i'm here
um that's what we want as a state
that's what i want as a parent i've got
three kids
who are in high school and middle school
and elementary school
that's what they want and and i faced
their judgment